keep tabs on every bucket mate then they
reseed the teams and have like a
semifinal and a final competition that
keeps the juices floor keep JIT compete
you know yeah oh she has been good for
you talk about Yana Street I've never
seen by name mixed it's okay let's off
because of the oddest dragon looking
dragon at the point tonight kick out
three on the way the Bucks have lived
with threes in the preseason 45 attempt
23 on you consistently just over two
minutes into this game the much down to
Brogdon puts up a three the Bucks are up
wants to have an awareness and quit
recognition what Zelo Zelo and the role
is open right there and Brogdon was
contested but there's to be is made up
for it in guile and understanding ninth
year in the league 28 years of age and
that young man has a long way to go in
his career
Christian would answer just under two
minutes now in the first bracket madness
off balance and play through contact if
you read it here I've been around a
while in 1987 let's watch welcome to the
tens oh and early no smash 4 on the shot
clock
back to the action
not a moment too soon turd that the old
but safe last minute race to the
opposite based on a good new fifth let's
up a bond this block and come back right
at that time setting the swing for
Simmons
Brogdon beats the buzzer plus the foul
[Applause]
just by the way this team is constructed
he can have an off night the Bucks could
still win and maybe win big
nice job the president's what you got to
do get it get it up there see him get a
couple threes to go to it's nice be
rewarded every once in a while
[Music]
ten please three times freakin they did
for that
back in active
Malcolm just getting into the first pick
of the draft the entree I command the
third inside as a phase girlfriend
[Applause]
there's a defense murdering the two and
a timeout taken
[Music]
you're drunk
[Music]
[Applause]
Buck's have scored 36 points in the
period with time to go unbelievable
paladin flies in and goes outside Stan
Lopez another recent credited for
Blagdon salad Xander wanted Harold
couldn't hang on Yanis she's a crowd a
gaggle of defenders so he goes to
Brogdon Canada and one Zanta watch the
opposite side with Trey Lyles who at 610
but he is a perimeter threat the student
percentage dozen and one Brogdon drives
and scores on jamal murray see the
quadrant gonna fill his than Brogdon
this is something that flares do a lot
it Malcolm Brogdon 63 59 shot big nice
job penetrating you see the deep it's
over commit too long of a run for Monte
Morris take that which into halftime
let's attack the basket Brogdon handle
on yes what first of all what is it a
stop secondly what is a fairly good
player and look at this him he is also
good
like his teammate that and quite frankly
I think everybody wondered him Creek
defense Brogdon and Lopez there's
somebody got a hand on it bragging now
[Applause]
and yes is found by a Turkish silky shop
isn't it fuller he's young nice to leave
three guns Craig Brackins
does now your fault
playing great team is losing the pieces
dreams are free
[Applause]
both teams total bad self best
possessions
a little frantic playa too fast
but on this send uncle Bogdan taking it
the differential between the game and
shot clock at six seconds
Bledsoe pregnant
yes
that's the crew
if fishing outstanding 3:05 on Three's
as well
Wetzel with a great kick out from
alchemy another guy who's just not
scared of the moment ready to shoot
knows a time on the clock
this time bribed in the recipient
bragdun hints in three-time after New
York it's the one to go with 18 percent
Humphrey
count the basket by Brogdon it's an and
won by Ibaka
Green finds the open three-point shooter
Malcolm crafting tie game let take the
shot
Middleton making the right play getting
in the paint finding the open shooter
Malcolm's
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
100 to 97 back-to-back triples for
Malcolm doing what makes him so valuable
and the next possession ball movement
again trusting each other
trusting the three-ball Bragdon steadied
the head of going to the basket this
time for a possible three-point play
clenched out to Harrison not literally
you can't do that great play black
Chris Middleton pulls in the rebound off
the Miss by Darius speller practice
he went right through Frank Jackson
seven points per mouth
Brogdon see key points against the yes
Crockett beats me James Wilson waiting
left right hand and inside DJ Wilson 14
straight threes another turnover from
New York Middleton with Yanis behind and
lobs it up and the den Akoo bow fires it
down with a left-handed again
so similar but the miscommunication look
in be honest but and miscommunication
here let's show points at the bench 1498
blood gentlemen's games at USC as a
freshman for him to be shooting 36% in
NBA the very honest gave it up for the
quadrant that they draw up in practice
from the three-point line straight on he
just sees a bigger spot oh gosh Janice
[Applause]
and easy plus the Bucks are shooting at
the lighted basketball talks about to
shoot bread and azar Brogdon to be going
great idea defenses News Nightwatch so
steps of [ __ ] Diaz Alice what a great
save there he goes down back
[Applause]
[Music]
and five spy maken two-handed hammer
that's a tough one otto porter a very
good defender it's long rich no way
trying to shoot open that's a tough one
excellent defense from behind knocking
it away here come the Bucks Brogdon
tony snell gets it back for walking a
big draft this summer three first-round
picks but John Collins but still to show
it to this play Spellman threw a bad
pass picked off by Brogdon he can't lay
em back Tony Snell flies to flush Tony
Snow on the run Brogdon flush
George Hill available Brighton for three
that's later oh no he was way behind er
it's not too late to make one more ring
right might be too late for the bonus
[Applause]
course
give me a service that's him what I
found but you've done a great job all
seasons the face on the offensive added
it's a hot potato underneath and it's
brown who comes over the fumble
[Applause]
let the 16 Milwaukee points to for one
opportunity here Ilyas over you bet
[Applause]
[Music]
Brogdon
[Applause]
walking in the first from the lawn at
the University of Virginia he can live
anywhere he wants now
touchdown they're evenly doesn't get all
the way to the class just as control
just flips it up a dozen points for
Brogdon steal Malcolm pass intended for
Kleber back to Brogdon
Lopez with a stick hand John Augustine
Augustine's quickness watch at Brogdon
in about Charles lead getting his wish
August knocked away by Lopez see that
much of the chance to go in that is a
black flag didn't count the basket and
one for Malcolm
his potential Harry Giles picks up his
first two points in the game Brogdon yes
beautiful drive with two bodies on him
at the last is involved in that also
maybe Brooks representing the NBA Andy
Brooks is in charge of innovation for
the league and there's different types
of innovation the good defense there he
is blew it up
rare contest Pat Connaughton he knocks
it away Brogdon beautiful pass he
wrapped it around in front of Buddy
hield Briana's asleep on pet Countians
ability to bother and block shots that
we're contests as you mentioned and
drugging with the beautiful but every
pet down and Bledsoe with a deuce for
seconds on a timer Connaughton racket
hits it three triples made by Milwaukee
in the overtime of the reaction Pat
Thompson here double-team kick-out and
Jack back winding down you see it two
for one opportunity for the Bucks
Brogdon splash Los Angeles ball 154 to
go in the fourth
dangerous inbound pass and Milwaukee
steals it in this corner Brogdon hits
the three
turnover after turnover this one on an
inbound you try to thread the needle to
LeBron James who has a defender in front
and behind AB for Milwaukee that was a
teardrop jumper by the beautiful
crossover Malcolm Brogdon
how about a three
Hey swish his fans a filling of Yanis
this is the free-throw Brogdon off the
hill about right continues to develop it
to a fine young prospect I really like
him a lot Jim he throws it away right to
Middleton nice pass ahead for flat so
reverse against all rich Eric Bledsoe
yes no hesitation off the front on the
three-point attempt Payton has it taken
away yes
[Applause]
where do you get your shots from with
the whites on the game brought them
forth
missmiss hidden the pump fake of mexico
box and he'll in the backcourt
Lopez's on from the beginning of Soviet
cotton
other 3/4
can't control
[Applause]
walking right there
here's Brogdon they don't want to foul
breathe
stepped away the owners
the night is over Mike Budenholzer just
pulling up from before
[Applause]
family of five for six from three-point
land
here's Brockton thanks Brian
down town gives to 100 seven-point lead
it wasn't